Dông lúc kể mưa đã trong 22 và giảng sáng 3 tháng 5 kế thiệt 2 tại nhiều tình thành miệnh bắt.
Tại tuân quan, kên dông kể mưa đã đừng tính một đến 3 cm của qua giả của nương, làm tắm người bị thương,
hàng trục quên nhà bị tất máy nhiều công trình hư hồng, hàng trục hết ta hoa mổ bị giập nát.
Chứ gọng trường trận là nó nó nó nó nghe trụng.
Mất liệu gái của qua nằm của máy mà nhà mà là cái này đi xa dạ.
Bạn sao?
Mình trong các xếp em, át tụng hết, bà lâu, trận em, tụng hái sánh.
Công thời điểm tại thành miên, gió lớn của mưa đã sẻ ra ở các xá hợp thành của lạc đại từ 5 thình.
Hến năm người bị thương hơn 8 chăm ngôi nhà hư hồng.
Mọi lúc bảo hông tham, cũng như nhiều lần gió nó sẽ là nhiều.
Các tính thành khác như biệt viên lại châu, lào cai, vũ thỏ và hà nội cũng khi nhận tình chẳng tương tự.
Chính quyền đảo vi động công an, quên đôi hỗ trợ người dân khác phục hậu qua.
Theo chúng tâm dự báo kỹ tượng thủy vàn khúc ra, hôm nay khúc khi lạnh tiếp tục nếm và đầy dạy át thấp xuống Việt Nam.
Bắt bộ có mưa vừa và dạy ra có dông, cục bộ có nơi mưa tò đến rất tò.
Trong mưa dông, người dân cần để phòng lúc sẽ mưa đã và só dịch mạnh.